bootleg help podcast man go watch the
full interview with the homie R mean but
you know his new album is out go uh
stream it it's just called mean it's
called mean uh manifest everything avoid
negativity but really mean which is what
everybody calls Nas is on the album
nozzle now that's really all you need to
know
thank you you wrote a song to NAS thank
you right yeah years ago I did a tribute
called letter to the king and then you
got a song with the [__] King and
then years later he heard it and reached
out all right let's let's just get to
this rapping because that's what our
army is a top tier my brother bar
yo yo bullet Kevin yes sir
[Music]
yeah at least top two in the game and I
ain't number two y'all the type to sit
on the toilet night just for number two
quick to follow me on IG and give me
your number two men lie women lie yeah
numbers two sipping on some Moscow Mules
before we rushing you dog I put the heat
to your noodle like you a cup of soup We
Them backpack boys I be blowing and
blowing slew real recognize real I don't
know who the [__] is you I really smoke
with the gods any toasted with knives
Rebels so with the cause went to war
with the odds see right through your
corny precise the skill is number one
never caught the lottery thinking and
steal my numbers one one of one I be
driving up lots to calling it feel like
pop Troublesome y'all get pop bubble gum
local Legend they call me no I'm not the
one you some more like Pops to some of
them Reach all my goals before I go six
feet in the hole before keep a piece of
my soul meat skiing the throw Elite slow
keeping seeds on their toes it's like
I'm injecting a hundred cc's of that
dope B leave each teeth that they show
fake Smiles give them free smokes like
the green leaves that we grow my 20
trees these streets got a cold dealing
with losses [__] Die Young I'm dying
from natural causes alone feeling cold
this evening call the phones and my dead
homies just to hit a voicemail greeting
yeah I don't feel they very far cause
they living in my hood got me wishing on
the store pretty women from Qatar given
to him brawl like abortion laws in Texas
don't exist Flex the coldest risk when I
rhyme so heavily it's like I'm spinning
the block trying to find your enemy
burning trees with burn see the size
Yosemite flow cold they should
cryotherapy
I'm paying taxes dog we in different
brackets face time with Jeff Hamilton he
killed the jacket Marathon the Mind stay
we on this Indie rap [__] put the money
up together then we split the back and
Dodge you fitted on my Dome I ain't
never capping consistency is key Homie
don't you get the slacking you won't
even need a chorus when you really
rapping Nas told me watch for these
[__] they distractions soak up
teachings a lot now I'm dropping gems on
a mob deep this and pop
[Music]
put my time in this game now it's time
that it pay me back it's the love of my
life Remy mine when she came with Pap 45
let the gauge clap all alone in these
streets like a stray cat bag on this
melon the honey G's worth squeeze till
his ass flat as b.o.b's Earth yeah we
talking money you know mean is with it
50 50 with my dog I ain't greedy with it
Street smarts plus he academically so
heavy start talking greasy academics on
a Henny she know the Vets raised me she
know the Rolex and the Rolodex crazy or
I Dash the wave see she know the [__]
that love me she know my ex hate me she
don't care about none of it could have
sex crazy ah they ain't live it they be
rapping only y'all should get a face
tattoo of a cap Emoji I be ducking the
feelings these [__] catching for me
still they do so I gotta stick and move
it's mean
ladies and gentlemen
the album is out right now me and
everywhere being out right now produced
by Scott Storage all Sky storage all Sky
storage thank you for having me my
goodness
fire hey I know you just watched the new
freestyle guess what we're dropping them
every week sometimes more than once a
week Jesus we've been dropping a lot
lately uh shout out to LRG don't forget
go to
l-r-g.com use the promo code bootleg
save 30 off at checkout you get this
look at this jacket look at that lining
it's LRG baby 30 off this bad boy go to
l-r-g.com promo code bootleg and save 30
off at checkout and check out another
freestyle next week